609 on your tuesday morning we've been
talking about it extreme heat is here
and we should never forget how deadly
the desert heat can be especially for
folks who work outside mary jane
valdezza live how do they how do they do
it mary jane
well nate you know working out in the
brutal heat it's always a challenge and
workers say they've had to find ways to
beat the heat every summer while there's
really no way to escape the heat when
you're outside workers say it's that
much more important to stay hydrated and
take frequent breaks it's also critical
to keep an eye on your co-workers as
temperatures rise so does the risk of
heat illness one construction owner
tailored around building outdoor sports
courts say it's all about adjusting
their working hours while one mobile dog
walker says their service is all about
keeping people and dogs cool too
this time of the year it's you've got to
beat the sun i mean our guys start as
early as like 6 a.m
um you know and then you're and then
you've got to cut it off a lot earlier
in the afternoon i mean it's not a nine
to five when you're working out in this
vegas climate it's more like six a.m to
maybe two a.m um you know naturally it's
a it's a dog exercise service so people
will use it um just for kind of physical
fitness for their dogs year round but um
summertime you know from from june until
october
about three quarters of our business is
people who are um
realizing that it's just dangerously hot
out and they can't walk their dog
during the summer those working outside
are more prone to heat related illnesses
heat exposure can occur indoors and
outdoors and any time during the season
if the conditions are just right and
health officials are advising you if you
have to be outside make sure you're
wearing light colored clothing wearing
your sunblock and of course taking
frequent breaks and drinking plenty of
water reporting live mary jane balliesa
live local now